THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
ELECTION DAY IN ALABAMA.
VOTERS HAVE THREE HOURS TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN REPUBLICAN
ROY MOORE OR DEMOCRAT DOUG
JONES.
POLLS CLOSE AT 7:00 P.M. LOCAL
TIME.
IT'S A RACE THE NATION HAS BEEN
CLOSELY FOLLOWING AFTER
"THE WASHINGTON POST" BROKE A
STORY LAST MONTH ALLEGING MOORE
AGAIN
ENGAGED IN SEXUAL MISCONDUCT
DECADES AGO.
CAN MOORE PULL OFF A VICTORY?
HE WAS DOWN TEN POINTS ACCORDING
TO OUR MOST RECENT FOXHOLE.
WE HAVE EXPERTS AT THE TABLE,
BRET BAIER AND MARTHA
MacCALLUM, HOSTING SPECIAL
COVERAGE.
WELCOME TO YOU BOTH.
ANOTHER ELECTION NIGHT.
I WAS SAYING TO SPADES, IT SEEMS
LIKE 2016 NEVER REALLY ENDED.
STICK AWAY BEEN COVERING THE
TURNOUT, WE'RE GOING TO GET A
SENSE OF THINGS.
INTERNET.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T WANT TO
KNOW.
I WAS JUST BEING POLITE.
>> Kimberly: HE ACTUALLY
INTERESTING TONIGHT ON THE ISSUE
WILL THE VOTERS SAY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S SO SERIOUS AND
SO GREAT JUST WHAT ROY MOORE WAS
ACCUSED OF AND HE SAYS HE DIDN'T
DO.
EDIT PRESSES THEM TO VOTE
AWAY FOR THAT.
YOU HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
CLAMORING DOWN THERE.
PEOPLE WHO CLEARLY WANT TO MAKE
THIS AN ISSUE GOING FORWARD.
IT'S GOING TO BE OUR FIRST TEST.
>> Jesse: IF HE WINS, LET'S
ASSUME FOR THE SAKE OF ARGUMENT
MOORE WINSTON WHAT'S THE MESSAGE
FOR OTHER POLITICIANS DEALING
IS IT, IS IT IF I DENY, DENY,
CONSPIRACY I CAN HANG ON?
>> OR THAT YOU ARE A REPUBLICAN
IN ALABAMA.
>> Jesse: A SPECIFIC STATE.
>> THE DEMOCRAT DOUG JONES HAS
IF HE WINS AND OUR POLL HAD HIM
UP 10 AS OF YESTERDAY, THEY SAID
IF HE WON, IT WAS GOING TO BE
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRAT COULD WIN
IN ALABAMA.
THAT'S IN DOUBT MANY YEARS
BECAUSE IT'S ABOUT AS DEEP RED
AS ANY STATE CAN BE.
>> Dana: PRESIDENT TRUMP ONE
BACK BY 20 POINTS.
MOORE COULD LOSE REPUBLICANS BY
THIS BEEHIVE IS GOING TO COME
DOWN TO GETTING THE VOTE OUT AND
HE WAS MORE PERSUASIVE IN DOING
THAT.
I WOULD EXPECT THEIR GROUND GAME
WOULD BE GOOD.
THE ADVANTAGES WOULD COME FROM
THE REPUBLICAN CANDIDATE, YOU
WOULD THINK.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAITED TO GET IN
ON THIS.
HE DIDN'T CONDEMN HIM LIKE
OTHERS DID BUT IS IT GOING TO BE
ENOUGH TO GIVE THE PUSH TO HAVE
THE POPULARITY AND GROUNDSWELL
SUPPORT FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP
TRANSFER TO ROY MOORE.
MY MIND.
DID YOU KNOW HIS LAWYER IS A JEW
DID YOU KNOW HIS LAWYER IS A JE
JEW?
I AM IN.
I DON'T EVEN VOTE IN ALABAMA.
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS WHOLE
ELECTION.
>> Dana: MAYBE WE SHOULD GIVE
SOME CONTEXT.
>> Greg: HIS WIFE SAID HIS
LAWYER IS A JEW.
>> THEY WANTED TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THEY WERE NOT ANTI-SEMITIC.
>> Greg: ARTIFICIALLY
POLARIZING CHOICE.
IF YOU VOTE DEMOCRAT, THEREFORE
YOU ARE VOTING FOR AN ANTIGUN,
ANTILIFE, PRO-ABORTION, AND
YOU'RE GOING TO BURN IN HELL.
BUT IF YOU VOTE FOR MOORE,
YOU'RE VOTING FOR A PEDOLPHILE
WE HAVE TWO CHOICES.
ABOUT, HE HAS SAID THINGS ABOUT
AND JEWISH, TO SUGGEST IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
THAT'S WHAT STARTED THE WHOLE
ANTI-SEMITIC ARGUMENT.
>> Kimberly: A LITTLE LATE IN
THE GAME FOR THE ENDORSEMENT.
>> Juan: THERE IS NEWS TODAY
FOR MITCH MCCONNELL JOSE LUTHER
STRANGE IS GOING TO STAY IN THE